Build it.
Draw it.
Play it.
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build it
Kevin Kulek made this one of a kind Duck Hunt
Pin Ball machine.
It's an electromechanical/ PC hybrid redo
of a 1962 Williams Valiant machine that took
about a year to complete and features manual
ball loading, original sounds and display.
Santa Cruz Skateboards made these Marge and
Maggie Simpson skate decks that come together
as a package.
Marge is 37.7 inches long and Maggie is 20.5
inches long and they are both 10.3 inches
wide.
And of course both have the ability to be
mounted with hardware and used like a regular
skate deck.
The Monkeys paw in Toronto features the biblio-mat
book vending machine that dispenses random
books for two dollars a piece.
Imagined and built by owner Stephen Fowler
and his friend Craig small.
Fowler imagined a box with an actual person
inside dispensing random books, and Small
took it to the next level by building an actual
mechanical vending machine.
Fowler sees it as a new spin on the dollar
cart that is classically in front of old book
stores.
Draw it
Russian Artist Svetlana Kolosova is a mother
of four that paints fairly tales on the palm
of her hand.
She was inspired by the stories she read to
her children but didn't have time to focus
on complex oil paintings, so she decided to
use the most convenient canvas around, her
left hand.
Inspired by the dapper criminal mugshots from
the 1920's artist Jason Mark re-imagines batman
villains in a vintage mugshot series called
"The usual Suspects" That includes Joker,Two
face, and Mr. Freeze.
And now for some nostalgic Nickelodeon art
celebrating the 90's
Paris based graphic designer Nacho Ormaychea
uses strange juxtaposition with the silhouettes
of pedestrians to frame photomontages of contradicting
images leaving the meaning behind the image
up to the viewer.
Play it
Nick Kosir is the rapping weatherman over
at KMTV CBS 11 as the morning meteorologist.
Paul Vo invented the VO-96 Acoustic Synthesizer
that creates new sounds on the acoustic guitar
through harmonic control of string vibration.
It has been tested and is ready to be produced
with the help of his kick starter page
YouTube channel Smooth Mcgroove does some
amazing one man acapella theme music.
Here's his latest video covering Corridors
of Time from Chrono Trigger.
Fianlly here is the officail video for "Mermaid's
revenge" from Turbogeist - directed my michael
mccool...
Submit your bidipis as a personal message
here on youtube.
Or share them with everyone over at Facebook.com/VsauceTwo
Click here to listen to bidipi radio.
Music created and submitted by you guys.
Also check out Your BiDiPi - an entire video
dedicated to your creations.
And as always...
thanks for watching.